[Music]
hello to all viewers welcome to our next
episode of watts of broth hello Walter
good day again to you how are you d I'm
doing just fine thank you glad ki
openness with us whether we're
absolutely our Heavenly Father the input
from the world out there is enormous
and you have given us guidelines in your
word as to how we should filter and salt
the information and I pray that you will
grant us wisdom in this process in Jesus
name Amen
so in the previous episode we discussed
a little bit on the videos that crops up
about Q and on and all these different
role players and I thought maybe it's
relevant that we talk about deception
now deception is is something which cuts
in many directions
the deception can be deliberate
deception can be incidental sometimes
people practicing deception do not even
know that they are practicing deception
because everybody is just using
information that comes to them and the
way in which they perceive the
information is the way in which they
will use the information so if you do
not have a guide book which again is
this Word of God then you will get lost
in the maze of deception because that's
what Jesus said he said the sign of the
times at the end is the first one he
mentions be careful lest anyone deceive
you
so filter everything through the word
basically is what we ought to do so will
you guide us but
in from both sides how this deception
can be implemented or how it's working
yes we have to keep in mind what is the
end game where are we heading and we're
getting information as we spoke about
queuing on for example from one side and
information from another side and it
seems as if there are these two parties
out there that are heading for a
confrontation and who are the role
players in the confrontation so it seems
as if two sides are crystallizing out of
this whole episode on the one side you
have those that have religion as their
basis and on the other side you have the
fear of dominance and control and giving
up your freedoms etc and that doesn't
necessarily have to be religious it can
be completely secular and how these
parties are driving men in a particular
direction and what can the outcome be
and when we spoke last time we said both
sides could be part of the deception
because that's how he gillian dialectic
works so let's have a look at a few of
the videos that are going around and
let's see if we can we can glean
something from them but of course we're
not going to say that this is what we
believe this video or this is what we
believe that video what is the the
information that eventually crystallizes
out in terms of the direction in which
we are going to move so please don't
misunderstand we're not showing videos
to say this is the site that we are
choosing or that is the site that we are
choosing we're just observers during
this game yes so let's have a look at
the first one
if this doesn't get rectified in the
very very near future within the next
few weeks our world and when I say our
world I'm not just talking about where I
live or where you live but our world our
planet is going to be a different place
they will be sicker they will be
controlled they will not have any
privacy they will not have any future I
want to make sure the world understands
where the problem lies
this is misinformation to the highest
order and the reason for this
misinformation is what's coming down to
the danger is not what's in front of you
the danger is what you're being
distracted from the only way that you
can control people is by keeping them in
ignorance the world needs to wake up and
understand that what's happening right
now is an illusion and it's going to
mandate other things coming down which
is include RF chips everybody's gonna
have mandated vaccinations so that they
can track those people and know who's
been vaccinated who's not been
vaccinated Stanford came out with a
study couple days ago the Stanford study
said this shows that the rate of death
from kovat 19 is no different from
influenza that's what the study showed
do you know what mainstream reported
that the study showed this is more
rampant than anywhere else on the planet
this is more rampant than we thought
well of course it is I think the entire
population of the world's been exposed
to it but they didn't focus on that part
if they said because a study in Stanford
said he said that we think it's much
more widespread but the death rate is no
difference in flu and in fact that's
based upon the data that they're giving
that they did this be reported for cause
of death but you know the means right
now you fall out of a plane without a
parachute cause of death Kovach 19 you
get shot in the head covered 19 killed
you you have a heart attack Kobe tonight
they're putting the cause of death is
COBIT 19 for almost everything right now
and you know we've heard this type of
information before some would call it
conspiratorial some would say it's
rhetoric but look right now you would
have to be blind and deaf to not
recognize that what is happening is
not normal and is not justified and
because they can't justify the numbers
they're now manipulating the numbers
they're now adding numbers to it
in other words the number of deaths
weren't sufficient to justify this so
they're now having not nurses and
doctors change death certificates after
the patients have died the only way that
you can control people is by keeping
them in ignorance but as soon as a
person becomes empowered with knowledge
the one thing is that nobody can control
you once you are aware you cannot be
victimized once you're aware and once
you've been empowered with knowledge
well what do we learn from dr. Bhutta we
could play much more of us but there is
this idea of we are being manipulated we
are being miscellaneous and obviously if
that is the case then there must be
somebody who is doing the misleading and
who are these people well they're sort
of crystallizing up who the deep state
is who the enemy is and the name that
always crops up is of course but gates
and anybody associated with them dr.
Falchi all of these things they they are
being portrayed as this force that is
trying to control everyone so that's one
side of the scenario we're not taking
sides here which is putting the
information that is out there yet a
perspective ok now this is not the only
one I mean there are literally hundreds
of them that are making the rounds which
sort of keep on telling us what the
situation is so let's have a look at the
next one when is Bill Gates's serpent
tongue going to come out of his mouth
and and when will his horns and tail
appear
this man is this man is is building
Lucifer's Antichrist system
this guy's an enemy the human race he's
an enemy of Almighty God Bill Gates is
turning out to
be one very evil man these people know
what they're doing their father is the
devil they work for Lucifer they know
who they're working for they know what
they're building
I would sell mr. gates right now you're
gonna have to kill me you're never gonna
get me to take your your vaccine or your
quantum dot whatever you'll have to kill
me and if mr. gates and other
billionaires continue to push their
agenda then they are going to push
people like me to call for the
confiscation of their wealth I mean it
if these guys continue this talk of
requiring mass vaccinations immunity
cards immunity passports microchips
buddy
you're you're starting a fight you you
wish you never started yes because the
American people will rise up and we will
strip you down to your tighty whities
mr. gates there'll be a populace revolt
that unites the left and the right don't
try to do this stuff to us look it's not
gonna be ankle bracelets it's not gonna
work Edward and and Christians had
better better get ready for a
confrontation with these people they're
coming after us and our families they
have an evil agenda they do and the
government needs to know there will be
an uprising if they try to do it there
will be blood in the streets if Bill
Gates pushes this agenda it will not go
down well Rick Wiles is sort of
representative of what many in the
Christian world believe especially in
some of the circles where this theology
of the microchip and all of these
or of course very prominent and and you
can see the anger yes and you can see
the fear so on the one side you've now
identified an enemy and you're going to
have a reaction against the enemy and
the reaction which you suggest is quite
drastic right so now how are you going
to resolve this issue how are you going
to resolve the issue between the so
called deep state which has this agenda
of enslavement and this idea that this
is part of the biblical scenario for
receiving the mark of the peace this is
part of the deception and we called it
double-blind right because you're
playing both sides of the fence
yes so we need to look at a few more
just to see where we're going
yes what was also interesting for me I
if you picked up that he said the left
and the right both of them will come
together to stand up against this yes
now the one side is concerned because of
their religious views and the mark of
the beast as they perceive it and the
other side is concerned about their
freedom yes and about their liberty so
both of them will come together
this is civilian dialectic how can a man
who's giving any any person who's giving
a global advice for health owned a
patent in the solution in the vaccine
isn't that a conflict of interest or
shouldn't it be it is a conflict of
interest and in fact this is one of the
things that I've been saying and would
like to say to President Trump
repeal the bayh-dole act Bible
fundamentally changed the way
universities approach technology
transfer and you can see that best in
the statistics universities obtained 16
times as many patents today as they did
in 1980
now this vid video is by Jenny wick of
it's right and
apparently worked with 4c and all of
these people and is a very prominent
scientist and the story about her
treatment and how she went to prison and
all of these things is is is fueling
this fire and of course she calls them
out and she says that what they are
doing is illegal
and now they are appealing to a savior
yes
a savior must come and resolve this
situation now again we're not saying
that this is deliberate or whether it is
fake or whether it is true that's not
the issue the issue is what is the
outcome going here is this heading
exactly so we can see a pattern
developing and this is very fascinating
because if you if you have the Word of
God as your basis and you see where the
deception lies then eventually the
pattern should be merged yes correct
so let's look at the next one could it
be that that President Trump right now
has been sort of raised for such a time
as this just like Queen Esther to help
save the Jewish people from an Iranian
Menace as a Christian I certainly
believe that's possible
the voice of evangelicals the Reverend
Franklin Graham says president-elect
Donald Trump was put in the White House
by God as you just heard there and we're
willing to listen to God's voice and I
believe this election no question I
believe God's hand was in it
gods used imperfect people all through
history King David wasn't perfect Saul
wasn't perfect I said mr. president I
know there are people that say you know
you said you were the chosen one and and
I said you were I am the chosen one
I think God calls all of us to fill
different roles at different times and I
think that he wanted Donald Trump to
become president and that's why he's
there and I think he has done a
tremendous job and supporting a lot of
the things that people of faith really
care about is he there for such a time
as this what is your views kind of
spiritually on the sovereignty of God
and and what he's doing exactly by
putting Donald Trump as president United
States well you know I think it goes to
show that things everything happens for
a reason
I see the greatest president in history
of course he is he was chosen by God it
wasn't about doing politics it was about
assignment to say no to president Trump
would be saying no to God
explain why you say that God has given
President Trump the authority to attack
North Korea
there is a great deal of confusion among
Christians when it comes to this idea of
using force to topple evil and I wanted
to clarify that I believe the Bible
especially Romans 13 does give President
Trump moral authority to use whatever
force necessary including assassination
or even war to topple an evil dictator
like Kim Jong hoon but this is the
greatest president for Jews and for
Israel in the history of the world not
just America Trump's the best president
for Israel in the history of the world
and the Jewish people love him like he's
the king of Israel they love him like
he's the second coming of God I find
that rather astounding so we are getting
the picture that the Christian world is
regarding him as the Savior now they all
know that he has shortcomings and we all
have shortcomings and they they use the
story of David to say that David had
shortcomings but he was a man after
God's own heart and therefore it doesn't
matter whether you are like this or like
that as
as you are being used by God to further
a particular agenda so yes now Donald
Trump is fascinating because he's often
depicted to be at loggerheads let's say
with the papacy regarding the wall for
example miss so Pope Francis says that a
person that erect swalls is not a
Christian and Donald Trump counters and
says well he doesn't really know me
doesn't know the problem at the border
he doesn't know any of these things the
Pope funded the caravan and yes yeah I
gave half a million dollars for for
funding the caravan so they seem to be
at loggerheads now what's interesting is
even though they seem to be at
loggerheads diversity each other they
exchange gifts they show solidarity when
they are with each other so what is this
animosity that is going on behind the
scene yes and he surrounds himself with
a lot of Christian leaders absolutely he
has a large council of advisors many of
them evangelicals many of them Catholics
his administration has many Catholics on
them they has public displays of
evangelicals praying over him etc so yes
there is this strange bond and yet he
has this strange Christianity where he
believes that you there's no need to
repent or to ask for forgiveness just
just do better work and carry on that
bother God with with the details of your
sin so we have this dichotomy on the one
hand you have this enemy and on the
and you have this potential Savior who
seems to be incapable of doing anything
at the moment because of the coronavirus
etc so what will come out of this is
actually what we are interested in so
let's have a look at another one now
some of these productions that we see
out there they see that something
doesn't quite fit and OnPoint
preparedness there's this this little
video where they are saying something's
not quite right because they're playing
both sides of the game and is there
something wrong here so not everybody is
choosing one side or the other some
people are standing back and asking the
question is there another agenda so
let's have a look at this one OnPoint
preparedness now I do love everything
that Donald's doing as president from a
worldly sense I love the fact that he's
securing the borders I love the fact
that he's focusing more on America I
love the fact that he wants to take down
the Federal Reserve and all these other
things but I also understand that
there's this principle of Ordo AB ko
or to order out of chaos and whether we
like it or not the current world order
is centered around America with the
American dollar being the world's
reserve currency and America being
basically a strategic geopolitical
nation that is sort of a glue that is
holding everything up today and so we
have to understand that when we start
retracting America back from the world
it is going to cause chaos and we know
exactly what ensues after that now I do
want to talk about Paulo White who is
Donald Trump's spiritual adviser she is
actually the person that is claimed to
have lead Donald Trump to Christ
now she is currently his spiritual
advisor she's currently mentoring him so
I think it's good that we take a look at
what type of person she is and what
she says about Christianity and her
beliefs according to Hebrews that Jesus
is our high priest and he's the first of
many brethren which means I now come
into a priestly anointing so I now could
say that again I now come into a
priestly anointing is not the only
begotten son of God he is not I'm a son
of the first forgiving you're that he's
the first-fruit he's the firstborn of
many Jesus is fount mind you this is the
woman that led Donald Trump to Christ
and is currently leading him that ties
in to our last video on the head
coverings and headship and authority and
so you see that there's something wrong
with that as well but she says that
Jesus is not the only begotten son have
you not read one of the most popular
verses in the Bible John 3:16 for God so
loved the world that He gave His only
begotten Son that whosoever believeth in
him should not perish but have
everlasting life
so for Paula to say something this
extreme is blasphemous it really is and
I'll show you why and mind you she is
the one that is a spiritual leader or
mentor of Trump so I mean I got to tell
you folks yeah I like everything he's
doing in terms of the presidency in
terms of worldly things but don't let
that completely cloud your judgment your
Christian judgment just like everyone
else we are to pray for him but too
frequently I see Christians clamoring
over him saying that he's gonna restore
Christian values much like Israel who
put his face alongside of a coin with
King Cyrus it really disturbs me
especially when he has not asked God for
repentance which is publicly on record
several years ago he is currently
surrounding himself with spiritual
advisors that are indeed false teachers
he's not bearing the fruit of the Spirit
it all is very concerning to me
considering the times that were in
and the fact that there will be a
Mystery Babylon which is a false
religion you can see very easily how the
promotion of a restorative Christianity
led by false teachers is not a good one
so yes really good things coming out of
the Trump administration in terms of
like worldly things and governments and
policies and things like that but we
have to understand the times that we're
in we have to have spiritual discernment
and I'll tell you what my antenna is
just like flying off the radar right now
with everything I'm seeing about him and
who he surrounds himself with this is
Mike with OnPoint preparedness guttin
bless everybody how does he do that he
does that through you he does that
through me wherever I go God rules when
I walk on White House grounds God walks
on White House grounds when I walked in
the river God walked in the river when I
go into the dry cleaner that dry
cleaning place becomes holy I had every
right and authority to declare the White
House as holy ground because I was
standing there and where I stand is holy
I find it incredible that God is subject
to our movement and we are not subject
to God's movement so people are seeing
that something is wrong but they're not
quite putting their finger on the pulse
and they realize that there is some
false teaching yet but what is the final
outcome that's what we have to look at
what is the final outcome because it
good well if you could say good but one
thing that's this is doing and the
person in the video also mentioned it I
said a lot of moral good is gaining
coming out of all of this correct
but is that the only thing that's coming
out of this exactly so where exactly is
this going to take us and are these of
conflicting sides really enemies or is
there a greater agenda behind the scene
playing the two
off against each other to prepare the
minds of the masses to accept something
this they've been some interesting
things happening in the world of late
and many people associate the events
with with the wrath of God and the anger
of God Utah earthquake damages Mormon
temple and knocks trumpet from ICONic
angel statue that that must have
surprised some people that the angel
Moroni who who gave those tablets to
Joseph Smith should be relieved of his
trumpet
they say hear the trumpet on the angel
Moroni statue fell off and there is
minor displacement of some of the
temples smaller spire stones spokesman's
for the church said now some people
might interpret this that God is
displeased about something and that is
why this happened so you know people
look at these things and are wondering
what's happening in the world now here's
an article from the National Catholic
Register and it says is the corona virus
pandemic a judgment from God so where is
the sinning is the corona virus pandemic
a judgment from God it is a question
being debated by many Christians this is
important even bishops and Cardinals
Pope Francis and the extraordinary
prayer service broadcast live from an
empty stand Peter's Square on March 27
prayer Lord you are calling to us
calling us to faith it is not the time
of your judgement but of our judgement
the time to choose what matters and what
passes away a time to separate what is
necessary from what is not it's
interesting out there using this
lockdown to define for us what is the
necessity and what is
not a necessity nice I mean the stores
you you can only buy what is the
necessity you walk in the store and in
the same store what's on the shelf they
it's got a tape over it you're not
allowed to buy that but you would like
to borrow what's next to it because this
is deemed a necessity by somebody else
now who defines what is a necessity
right but nevertheless half the human
race is under some form of lockdown as
if suddenly consigned to an involuntary
retreat have we sometimes failed to
honor the Lord by keeping the Lord's Day
this is fascinating because we have in
our lectures consistently said that the
issue is not a microchip the issue is
who do we honor with our obedience who
do we acknowledge as the Supreme Being
in our lives is it God and His Word or
is it the church and their word and we
know that Roman Catholicism has changed
the law of God and that the Christian
world is running with the papal
commandment in that they observe the
first day of the week and not the
seventh day of the week by the way when
we talk it I'm off topic now but if we
talk about the cosmic week if you're
going to move that seventh day the
millennial period to the next day which
would then be the next first day of the
next week or the eighth day and you're
actually cutting out the millennium and
you're cutting out the millennium of
God's rest yes that would be a disaster
because that means there is no
millennium and that's exactly what
Catholicism teaches it teaches a
millennia nism the church will rule
there is no such thing as a millennium
where Satan would be bound and most
Christians out there also believe this
that the thousand years will be ruled on
earth absolutely whereas God clearly
says that the
sites will be taken away and Thrones
will be set up and in in heaven and not
here on earth but be that as it were
he's asking is there a problem because
we have not honored the Lord's Day have
we treated Sunday just like any other
day as a time to go shopping get work
done and pursue our own agenda instead
of taking time to deepen our
relationship with Jesus and relax with
family and friends
now that cuts both ways spending time
with Jesus that addresses the religious
world spending time with family and
friends that addresses who are both but
the secular world as well in the Old
Testament God decreed that Judah would
go into exile for a time time
corresponding to all the Sabbath's they
had broken until the land had retrieved
it's lost Sabbath's so now perhaps our
frenetic society is retrieving it's lost
Sabbath this is where it's actually
heading now in how far is it being
implemented now how far are they testing
the implementation of this exactly let's
look at this but Francis this is Zenit
news day of prayer and fasting and works
of charity on May 14 that was the
original date when he was going to have
this meeting with the leaders of the
world and the creator's think tank on
re-educating humanity Pope Francis has
accepted the proposal from the high
committee of human fraternity for May 14
2020 to be a day of prayer and fasting
and works of charity to implore God to
help humanity overcome the corona virus
pandemic so they ask is the pandemic
because God is displeased because we
have perhaps not keeping Sunday now
they're gonna have a day of fasting and
prayer the Holy Father and just for
interests sake the Bible says call
nobody father except of
earthly father was your father and your
heavenly father but you're not supposed
to call anyone else in terms of
religious environment your father
and nobody is holy except God so he was
praying here on this palace which is
associated with Mary and he said we
began May a short while ago
Marian month par excellance during which
the faithful love to visit shrines
dedicated to Our Lady Pope Francis said
this year because of the health
situation we go spiritually to these
places of faith and devotion to place in
the holy virgins heart our worries
expectations and plans for the future
and as prayer is a universal value I've
accepted the proposal of a higher
committee of human fraternity so that
may 14 believers of all religions unite
spiritually in a day of prayer and
fasting and works of charity to implore
God to help humanity overcome the corona
virus pandemic remember May 14 all
believers together believers of
different traditions to pray fast and do
works of charity this is a typical
response you go to shrines you do things
in order to get the attention of God God
is right next you we're supposed to have
a personal relationship with God in the
system there are mediators but God wants
us to talk to him directly America the
Jesuit review these are interesting
sources yeah but Francis joins Muslim
leaders in calling for World Day of
Prayer to end the coronavirus so this is
obviously a mobilization of religion but
Francis calls our believers of all
religions to pray together on May 4
to ask God to rid the world of the
pandemic and ask that the vaccines to be
made available to all persons threatened
with infection so what side of the
divide is you're on right now you've got
this again you have the people that says
the vaccine is the enemy and here it's a
frame it's a frame the Francis has
endorsed the call to the believers of
all the religions to unite together
spiritually on May 14 in a day of prayer
and fasting to implore God to help
humanity overcome the corona virus
pandemic he also encouraged
International Cooperation to respond to
the crisis and emphasized the importance
that scientific effort to find a vaccine
to put to be put together in a
transparent and disinterested way and
that the essential technologies be made
universally available so he's asking for
the vaccine and people are you know
going against the vaccine we have this
interplay all the time no matter where
you look and where does the United
Nations stand in all of this UN chief
supports higher committee of human
fraternities call to pray for your
manatee on the 14th of May so this is
not just one religious leader asking for
something we have the major religions
coming together we have the governments
of the world because that's the United
Nations doing exactly the same things
Goethe res tweeted on Sunday and
difficult times we must stand together
for peace humanity and solidarity this
is an illusion to the common good right
yes I joined His Holiness Pope Francis
and the grand Imam of al-assad Sheikh
Ahmed el-tayeb and their support for the
prayer of humanity this 14th May a
moment for reflection hope and faith so
all of humanity is associated in this
movement now I found this one
particularly interesting this is one of
the political parties they call it a
far-right party in in Europe and these
parties are gaining in popularity and
they used the statement by Netanyahu's
son and he suddenly became a star of the
German nationalist party after calling
the EU evil
now remember Netanyahu is Jewish right
so this is a young Jewish boy and he is
calling the EU evil and this party has
latched on to the slogan now where's
this going the lawmakers tweets poster
quoting yen at Yahoo after the Prime
Minister son appealed for a return to a
free democratic and Christian Europe I
have consistently said this eventually
because of the fear of being swamped
they will return to Christianity the son
of the Israeli prime minister has become
the new campaign face for the far-right
alternative for Germany the AFT party
after calling the European Union and
evil globalist organization so here you
have globalism with the main globalist
role players against nationalism and
Trump is of course the champion of
nationalism and they are the champions
of globalism and Christianity is the
remedy that isn't that facilities
christianity is the remedy for the evils
of the globalists so you're playing the
two sides off against each other right
yeah Netanyahu could suite it alongside
a poster that reads
Schengen is dead well it's interesting
that closed all the borders right
hopefully the globalist EU will be too
then Europe will again be free
democratic and Christian Netanyahu later
tweeted back at coos writing please act
with your colleagues to stop this
insanity with a link to a page on the
NGO Monitor website that describes how
the German federal government provides
millions of euros to political advocacy
NGOs in Israel the West Bank Gaza
through a variety of frameworks we have
one day in a year to remember our fallen
soldiers and you destroy it with a
memorial to Palestinian terrorists EU is
an enemy of Israel Trump is the friend
of Israel and an enemy to all European
Christian countries Schengen zone is
dead and soon your evil globalist
organization will be too and Europe will
return to be free democratic and
Christian but how doesn't the Bible say
that the ten horns will give their power
unto the Beast now when they were a
Christian political religious
conglomerate in the Dark Ages then all
power was given unto Roman Catholicism
the Pope is appealing for people to join
up and here you have exactly the same
call go back to your Christian roots now
when they do that don't you think they
will introduce legislation that is in
harmony with papal legislation again yes
and when there are laws in the Middle
Ages banning Saturday keeping
decrees against those that kept the
Sabbath of the Vogons Ian's the AL
begins Ian's all of these groups were
persecuted relentlessly are we heading
in that same direction now this is a
very interesting one and if you found
this right he is I heard a bit about it
and then I saw that there's quite a
different stories about this st. Corona
so nobody has exactly this story the
story goes that it might have been nice
meant and wife that were persecuted and
then martyred for their religion and
then now because of the coronavirus a
lot of Catholics went now because st.
Corona along with st. Victor are Saints
and now they were asking is st. Corona
the patron saint for epidemics but she
wasn't really the patron thing but it's
a it's a nice name - couple - right and
what's interesting is the feast day for
Saint Corona it's just interesting it's
14 May that is fascinating how do you
think that is coincidence that st.
Corona should have a feast day which is
a national day of fasting and prayer and
good works and that she has exactly the
same name I find this interesting
so according to the Roman mayor
Martyrology the Catholic Church's
officials list of recognized Saints and
people who have been beatified as Corona
was dying she saw two crowns falling
from heaven one for Victor and the other
for herself
the Martyrology says and then what was
also interesting for me Nia is
coronaviruses unnamed for they crown
like spikes on the surface according to
the Centers of Disease Control and
Prevention corona means crown in that
it's just interesting how they link this
yes a corona of course is also the blaze
around the Sun there are a lot of
parallels that you could draw and play
with and keep yourself occupied but we
are interested in where the gallery here
we go so let's have a look at how the
various countries have responded and
what they have brought in in order to
control the coronavirus yes yeah not all
this legislation is now as a consequence
of Corona for example Poland and many of
the countries of the former East Bloc
have actually introduced Sunday
legislation already and even Germany had
very strict rules regarding Sunday I
think Austria as well yes exactly so
Sunday trading ban is already in place
in many places like Poland the Sunday
trading ban took effect in 2018 and it
was incremental nice so this webpage
tells us how it was going to be
implemented and that first there was
going to be one Sunday a month in two
then three and eventually it would be
completely closed so as a general
overview in 2019 there are 37 Sundays
with the trading ban meanwhile in 2020
customers won't be able to do their
shopping for 45 Sunday's of the and it
will just a little increase until all
the Sundays are closed so it was brought
in incrementally it's like something
sneaking up on you I am something in the
pipeline something in the pipeline now
for terekhov as a result of the covered
knife this is a governor extends
lockdown and curfew key deadlines and
government measures and response to
curve at 19 so if you do not adhere to
the violation too
rules and regulations you can be quite
seriously find violators may face a six
months jail term or a fine of up to
$5,000 it's interesting that we have
just received guidelines as well in our
country yes for violations of the
restrictions that have been put in place
now please we are not advocating
violating any restrictions no that is
not the aim of this we are just looking
at a trend where we going yes so if
there are legislations that are not in
contradiction to God's law then we are
supposed to obey the powers that be so
limiting traffic and then no one may use
their cause on Sundays
that's an interesting law except in case
of emergencies and increasing business
closures on Sundays grocery stores must
remain closed on Sundays and pharmacies
will only be allowed to sell medicines
and personal hygiene products gas
stations may only sell fuel so this is a
slow encroachment wondering will these
laws be relaxed again or will they stay
in place where did they where did these
laws come from yes who made them why
Slovenia it seems increasingly likely
that the closure of stores including
groceries on Sundays as a result of the
corona virus epidemic will become
permanent arrangement and be extended
also to the period after the crisis now
isn't this exactly what we've been
speaking about for yes yes and it's it's
not in your face
everybody is okay with us because this a
common enemy here coronavirus yes
correct
a legislative initiative to this effect
announced by the opposition left was
backed on Thursday by Prime Minister
Yanis Johnson announcing the legislative
proposal the Left joined today the trade
unions of shop assistants now a few
years ago I gave some lectures about how
Sunday's legislation is encroaching on
Europe and what the bishops conferences
had decided and it was fascinating that
all the trade unions of Europe were on
board with Sunday legislation and here
again you have the trade unions involved
the Left pointed out that voters had
already decided in a referendum in 2003
that stores should be closed on Sundays
but were ignored later due to pressure
from retailers now what's interesting
for me on that is it's not against what
how the people feel if people wanted
this yes the people wanted and the
Christian will answer is the Christian
world wants this to happen
absolutely so is it possible that your
fear of the mark of the beast as a chip
can lead you to accept the mark of the
beast without you knowing that you've
actually gone from the frying pan into
the fire
this is what we are looking at is what
we're looking at shops in Croatia to
close on Sunday trading however has been
banned on Sundays the head of the
National coronavirus crisis management
team Interior Minister buzzy Novick said
on Saturday that the decision banning
Sunday work was made based on
recommendations by epidemiologists
calling that's interesting
to these the scientists say it's based
too close on Sunday declining to comment
on the speculation that the present
situation was being used for political
purposes now epidemiologists decide that
closing on Sunday is is a good idea why
not Saturday or Wednesday or Monday or
whatever because the human psyche is
geared for this and they're ready for it
and this is exactly what the Bible says
would happen
CNN reports total lockdown in General
Santos City every Sunday are we seeing a
talk about Sunday legislation well it's
not it's not that's a national law yet
but it is being introduced piece by
piece
now there's a statement in the spirit of
prophecy said that says when they start
talking about Sunday legislation there's
really time to be serious and to leave
the cities for example so a total
lockdown will be imposed every Sunday
starting April the 5th so these things
are happening
Giavotella Philippines this isn't the
Philippines yes here's a government web
page regarding the Cayman Islands for
example a hard curfew from 8 p.m. to
5:00 a.m. daily in and all day on Sunday
that's interesting we also have curfews
in are currently between 8 p.m. and 5
a.m. yes correct
so is this being orchestrated why should
it be the same in the Cayman Islands
southern Africa other portions of the
world there must be a power that is Co
or denying the movements and also
interesting on this one for me is that
there's a difference you've got soft
curfew and hard curfew and the Sunday
falls then under the hard curfew yes
very interesting and again you are
liable to fines and imprisonment of six
months if you contravene any of these
restrictions no under it's on the soft
curfew another hard curfew $3,000 fines
so that's it's a considerable amount of
money to be fine yeah if you transgress
the Sunday curfew at all because you
that hard curfew is the whole day do you
think that this could be expanded to not
being able to buy or sell at all if you
do not go along with this particular
legislation I think it can move towards
it here's the Cyprus mail coronavirus
shoppers and supermarkets say sunday
closing makes no sense shoppers and
supermarkets alike are unhappy with the
latest restrictions imposed by the
government that will see supermarkets
closed from this Sunday now so here the
people are not too happy about it
exactly but there's not much they can do
about know it's there it's been done and
the people haven't been us they whether
they agree with it or not for sure it is
a mistake to restrict ours even more so
more people will be in the supermarket's
at the same time they're saying well if
you close one day then you're pushing
everybody into the other days but it's
heading this way whether we like it or
not
here's another webpage this is now
Greece government announces changes to
supermarket hours no more Sunday opening
the government on Tuesday announced
changes to supermarket opening hours and
they will be closed on Sundays
the opening of supermarkets on Sunday
has been broadly denounced by labor
groups again you have the trade unions
as an unacceptable burden on supermarket
workers interesting that some countries
the people are for it and under others
against it but that doesn't stop them
from doing it exactly but the trade
unions yes they are all on board now if
you go into the history of the trade
unions where trade unions started you
will see that it comes from the ramen
activists Roman Church okay
yes beliefs complete shutdown announced
for businesses in Chaya on Sunday
Sundays and the KO district there must
be a complete shutdown of businesses any
movements on Sunday must be by essential
workers only or for emergencies only
the public is urged to comply with the
regulations it's amazing how it just
sneaks in everywhere
here's one from albania albanian
government tightens restrictive measures
emits covered 19 again we have
prohibiting all activity and movement on
sunday the world seems to be heading
towards sunday legislation and it's not
a newspaper saying this this is
legislation already yes this is latest
now accepted after the coronavirus sure
but once it's there why would they
retract it and one thing in the near
future if a greater epidemic emerges yes
but they they are sneakier than that
even because they've already linked
sunday to the environment yes
so the planet needs a day of rest so
once this is already in place and Lodato
see asks for sunday to give the planet a
day of rest well then why would you
remove it you're already in
compliance with with climate change
legislation there that's interesting
because climate change will also fall
under disaster absolutely now this is
the disaster legislations that's being
implemented correct and here as they
independent coronavirus Peru announces
social restrictions by gender it gets
rather interesting men will be allowed
to leave their homes on Monday Wednesday
and Friday
while women can go out on Tuesday
Thursday and Saturday on Sunday no one
is allowed to leave home so sunday is
constantly separated from the rest of
the week so the first day of the week is
being targeted and the seventh day of
the week well you can go shopping on
Saturday it's not an important day and
this one is Peru but also it mentions in
this article Panama has been the same so
these are the South American countries
so these trade unions are going to be
very involved now it's interesting that
we have these statements in a spirit of
prophecy the trade unions will be the
cause of the most terrible violence that
has ever been seen amongst human beings
we're going to see this in the in the
cities and we in South Africa have a
fair amount of experience as to what
happens when the people are angry here's
another statement and the trade unions
will be one of the agencies that will
bring upon this the time of trouble such
as has not been since the world began so
there is something that is waiting for
us
and I believe the cities are going to be
hot beds of strife yeah and this article
said with that now you've also seen that
a lot of the trade unions are involved
absolutely now these were all the
countries now what about the United
States the United States is supposed to
take the lead right and the governor of
New Jersey made some interesting
comments there were of course other
governors in other states that said now
we'll stick to the Constitution which
separates church and state but in New
Jersey the story was different
let's have a look further I am directing
all non-essential retail businesses to
indefinitely close their physical stores
to the public effective at 9 p.m.
tonight only in by the way 9:00 p.m. in
particular out of respect to the Sabbath
only business is critical to our
response may remain physically open to
the public I think it needs a Bible
study as to which day is the Sabbath is
of course referring to Sunday as being
the Sabbath which is not the Sabbath the
seventh day is the Sabbath of the Lord
our God what's interesting is all the
sentiments are towards Sunday everybody
all the countries that we've seen
everything is geared towards Sunday
correct yes absolutely now I'm wondering
how they came to get around this because
it is obvious that we have a clash here
between God's rest day and one that was
changed by man even if it was a church
with not one Bible text to substantiate
their view this one here from Grenada
was very interesting I think you said
they retracted this right because he's
president not 100% certain but I think
that was what happened there was
opposition against this and then they
retracted it so the government
Ranade is assuring the population that
the announcement of Saturday 11 April as
the next shopping day is not meant as an
affront to any religion so here they
were advocating one day for shopping is
their 24-hour curfews and you were only
allowed to go shopping on the day that
the government said this is an open day
to go shopping and that happened to be a
Saturday yes so if you kept the seventh
day then you couldn't go shopping and
you couldn't get to essentials now this
is just a mode of slow encroachment so
do you think that in the near future
there could be laws judging from all of
these things that would say Saturday you
will work Saturday is the day that will
be like a normal work day and Sunday
everything will be closed you know what
was interesting also is the reason why
they said their to do the shopping on
the Saturday is that again the
scientists were telling them that that
was working out to be the base day for
it and one wonders why why one day would
be better than another day so it comes
back to every time when the science
shows something to be okay then if
government says also it's okay then we
can implement it yes now what will
happen if you get the government's to
start saying global warming we have to
have a good day off we have to then have
a sixth day workweek to bring the
economy back when the papacy gets all
the the people in the know together and
decide how to re-educate but the
reallocation has already actually
started we are being attuned to a
particular way of living and thinking so
the bottom line of our little discussion
today was the
real aim is a confrontation between the
Word of God and the dictates of men for
in vain they worship Me teaching for
doctrines the commandments of men that's
what Jesus said and Jesus was perfectly
clear that he did not come to abolish
the law not one jot or one tittle would
by any means disappear from the law so
the world is heading in this direction
and we just substantiate and confirm the
fact that time is short we are going
home soon amen let's pray will you pray
for us I will bring oh Emily father
thank you so much for the privilege of
us having this discussion we ask that
you bless the viewers and bless us as
well in Jesus name Amen
amen
thank you for watching this video to
subscribe click here when the bell
appears click and you will receive
notifications to watch the next one
click yeah thank you again and see you
next time